I can't batches and okay I'm pitches now
it should buy psychobabble it's for the
wobble but I placed with templates
because I want to get my tip wet so
let's service oh shut i hear it's a
scary [ __ ] game oh great then I then
why aren't you hoping Lana this is an
emergency life or death situation that
requires your immediate attention trying
once again can't man this is a very
serious situation oh please activate the
terminal in front of you and follow the
instructions IKS templates lab member
access point input stored pretty use
terminal how you feelin today now that I
got I got a [ __ ] listen I'm going to
be honest with you there was no
emergency I was simply evaluating your
ability to respond and react to a
stressful situation god that's my job
I'm here to help you thank you so do you
really want to try this again you've
been at this for far too long and for
some reason you seem really stressed out
your answers from the questionnaire they
weren't incorrect just not what I was
looking for okay do you at least
remember how this all works remember and
X woodland ridge very impressive this is
all a very good sign when you're ready
you may enter the simulation okay just
up inside
broken I guess okay i guess im gone into
woodland read relax relax chef the first
time I woke up like a cave but I potato
dad I mean I slave slave right it was
coming for a while what a [ __ ] mess
okay what's lucky eh let's look here oh
it's beautiful hello butterfly each egg
to get your tip wet too huh well I'll
tryna get a tip but in this crazy world
you know thank you i am I supposed to go
how do you always respond well to that
memory it was from a better time in your
life before the endless hours of hard
work and regret that destroyed yourself
worth and forced you to question all the
choices you've made a gay money perhaps
things are different now are you ready
to continue yes I hope you are a mental
fortitude to remember what happens next
something very meaningful had occurred
how do i go back to this
a fact that [ __ ] the office
your office you are always there
let's say look at night I tonight
working hard shall I get that money 1201
not too late for me what you know and
it's sleep when those chemicals hello
hello hello look closer oh [ __ ] remember
once you saw the blue butterfly yes I
did okay Santa casing wrong but the alla
Mia Morgan I all these guys not pursuing
about you I'm not ready to lay [ __ ]
Morgan's in the Hat watcher oh my god
Morgan I say you Morgan yep works dad
got subject case awesome grabs the
Lovecraft Erica analyst simulation
something's going on
subject x it's gonna be some clothes
hair you know so I can't let's see is
his this Ally be to him a semblance
laughs as the designs tificate
appreciation very nice call I can't
tonight I can't get it that's yeah
that's yeah that's your cells Thurman
exposures a gag like a perv sorry talk
to hang out Morgan Lewis okay i'm not
worthy mention latest rumor external
illuminator rectangular field and in
clubs reports of on puzzle totally and
I'm like a man as an asst you seem to be
making connections to your past I'm glad
you haven't completely lost your mind
yeah let's continue with this train of
thought and see where it takes you at
gammage
china hot ok back to here did she see
the butterfly
back there still we can go faster I
don't like walking so much in games as
this butterfly hello MA not me here for
you I'm here for sure like a path I
could flag on Zach really nice place
nice trace you can see they got lazy
there's the wall okay I supposed to exit
to her here no
that's every year
hello hola
amazon er I'm here
what's that a little light up there
to look closer
what's in here nothing
let me take something here
faculty office
Oh
the campus is critical only for recent
memories but not for older ones over
time and the campus teaches the
surrounding brain the cortex how to
represent a memory and an alternative
theory accounts for these discrepancies
by proposing that the hippocampus
selectively stores one type of memory
Masonic of the surrounding cortex stores
and other semantics with you in
recording and how this is another copy
is simply another copy
copy many times in both the hippocampus
and the cortex all of those cortical
copies generate a new semantic in theory
if you were to store these memories it
would be possible to preserve their
integrity this is of course assuming the
memories were accurate to be good okay
cuz I was not change back to you last
night working my hug wrap blah maybe
glitch protected memory very weird
that's all I gotta say yeah what's on
the computer again remember what you saw
the butterfly you bet your ass I did I
pour it on here let me some porn
hissing without fan
okay then I activate with everything any
of that night so I trying to exit what
is that suck got that
I didn't I remember and
what the [ __ ]
hello ma'am tell me what's it out it's
checking my chain here there are some
enough to do back in here
we didn't interact with that butterfly
it said remember when she saw the
butterfly alright [ __ ] you're gonna get
me answers you're gonna tell me what I
want to know oh shut i remember
something Oh
what I'm waiting for you why don't you
hope it this is an emergency life
buttons Jewish back and requires your
immediate attention maggots right once
again this is a very serious situation
knocking angry and that's a guy i miss
activate the terminal in front of you
that follow the extra banger yeah but
sure listen I'm going to be honest with
you there was no emergency right now I
was simply evaluating your ability to
respond and react to a stressful
situation that's my job I'm here to help
you dang cow so where should we begin
what do you remember uh uh honest Sarah
learned about your current mental state
sorry well your answers from the
questionnaire very concerned seer you
show me last porno let's remember how
this whole works yes yes does this place
look familiar man this is your chin yeah
where you lived with your wife hello
babe a very sad books here Shep the
shack okay
I la master 9 8 10 sorry i don't really
true hamilton and grow kabhi kabhi i
love gotta follow up and either and [ __ ]
in here I got him beautiful day I havoc
let's say yeah let's see it can I got
here hey David each other's fight
there's my cap again I can't allow Oh
Chrissy Alice foundation my further
isn't more I can do outside performance
and it's a true one thing that drives a
change our mutual problem the loss oh so
some [ __ ] died i think this krissy
Alice it's like when [ __ ] dick
Chrissy house is like a really hard
shell like a butterfly goes into and
like stayed there for long felt like it
took a kind of prisoner like stay long
time to the probably like preserving
yourself for like life or death hello no
my wife where's my life where's my wife
looking for my baby girl what this is
really nice guy holy [ __ ] ok God got hey
me again it's about quarter after five I
just try to get the office but you
didn't answer listen you need to be
careful your theory is based on initial
assumptions that may not be accurate you
could hurt yourself also we need to talk
about 5 58 f you know I can't just sit
here and watch time go by get back to me
I can't match hey me again it's about
quarter after five I just try to get the
office but you didn't answer what's that
girl's ugly you need to be careful your
theory is based on I gotta get that back
out here this is all happening too fast
not like before we don't want you to end
up like never mind what I said it's
important that you remain calm and
follow any memory you can at this point
I gave beds back of the up always coming
back to the office so many problems
you've created haven't lately out if
only you had more time that the ants
the time yes we did it baby it's earlier
the day it is earlier in the day I have
changed the clock its market it's my gun
may these change
morgan is a hat lodger
my reduction or useful katonic aboard a
part of our trenches the up the
assembles project shaman meets a
violation must stop me danger okay so
what's going on here what's the new
thing there must be possible we can
force ourselves to deliberately forget
through EEG measurements we should be
able to capture the exact oh it's
[ __ ] later than it was before let's
say for example
okay later sometimes I get concerned
that false memories are being planned to
do
I'll be the back office vixen excess
match [ __ ] is broken you have one new
message lift today it's not 121 a.m.
where are you damn jay says China
[ __ ] work here all these distractions
so something very strange happened while
you were in there remember when you
discovered that the coefficient of the
time spent remembering bad memories is
directly dis proportional to the time
you've been regretting that time
invested
back to the house I guess
please don't make things worse yeah not
like that okay but sit here now and shin
yang it's our clock that I could send it
back what the [ __ ] is that a little boy
another love Y and may a little boys
little boys okay that's someone's out
here a shot where's my baseball again
[ __ ] dark in here is what it is great
hello thank ya [ __ ] talk out here okay
let's like em I got all hat now I can
read the [ __ ] now
ok so i guess the son died i try and
bring back those on I hate this banning
it's a [ __ ] ugly
ok
[ __ ] psycho [ __ ]
obituary
Jason
okay here we go access to this part of
your memory is not permit holy [ __ ]
don't be angry it's all part of your
design you're not ready trust me [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up okay if I just go back
there
you like that check on back in there
okay blue Beckett I'm
I'm afraid I can't let this continue I
don't think you're ready for the truth
[ __ ] SI ya play this game huh I play
this game anything chasing this Ridge
I'm here betch tell me the answer tell
me what I want to know
[ __ ] are you okay okay let's go back to
the office I guess I always go back to
work
[ __ ] Anna I've Tony to its earlier in
the day change it again how can I call
my wife my beautiful life
I'm a flashlight now what can I do
butterfly
it must be possible we can force
ourselves to deliberately forget through
EEG measurements we should able to
capture [ __ ] the stores open my sister
always suck it open
ok
I might buy
ok that's the cell fila contain maternal
and companion but maybe pppp pppp did
emergency shutdown tall over there hey
I've done
ok so the AI you like so working it's
like [ __ ] up so I gotta shut that
[ __ ] down what is this a
bedroom kitchen oh there's it another
way to where that person is I can go
there
[ __ ] okay
to get him pretty clever it's getting
pretty clever
get the [ __ ] out of here I've seen
enough mesh ok so I have the emergency
shutdown which I could do it open
and what if I try off that door
nothing's in here right now I think it's
this dork snake in now what if I check
out the store during the daytime man
like that okay with this thing right
[ __ ] is up okay
I will fly through again here I got bet
says all out to your seat belts can I
ask for it again
repeating this action is not productive
instead maybe you should bury yourself
in your work like you always do I'm
gonna shut this [ __ ] down what are you
doing there's nothing back here of any
interest I'm gonna set sit down [ __ ]
I'm gonna go check out what's in that
memory okay please be careful nobody
knows exactly what that control panel
does I think it's mislabeled wait please
stop I was just about to tell you
something very important please shut up
i got better listeners [ __ ] wine okay
I'll bet shean here to see my wife okay
Debbie
they say now I'm stopping me now from
finding the answers psychobabble
Virginia's
hi bad shots got here
ash
yes
that's what's gone
I'm afraid to turn around now shut what
the [ __ ] all right well if you guys are
questioning my tip is wet let me tell
you it's wet ok [ __ ] wet I sure could
use the AI again
what the line [ __ ] say brazen yard save
me
their shadow
she never understood why never mind just
remember with sometimes I get concerned
that false memories are being planted in
your life everything you've seen is a
version of the truth a semblance of the
past hmm [ __ ] weird is what this is
I can't i add
okay sometimes I get concerned that
false memories are being planted in
turbine yeah I like stuck in a [ __ ]
look I know you're confused right now
how this all started there was an
accident do you remember what happened
it's your fault for walk into that I
know you're confused right now help us
all star
let's go [ __ ] dogs
why aren't you hoping this is an
emergency life or death situation and
requires your immediate attention once
again this is a very serious situation
[ __ ] that man bets please activate the
terminal in front of you happy I follow
the instructions listen I'm going to be
honest with you there was no emergency I
was simply evaluating your ability to
respond and react to a stressful
situation that's my job I'm here to help
you so do you really want to try this
again you been at this for far too long
and for some reason you seem really
stressed out and there the answers from
the questionnaire are exactly what we're
looking for you at least remember how
this whole works
ah corrupt there I before you continue
you should know this memory appears to
be corrupt and unstable you can enter
but there's no guarantee you'll be able
to return I assure you however there are
answers inside in six seconds the field
containment will collapse and the memory
will be lost forever you must decide the
choice you've made is a predictable
monthly but understandable back in space
it's often easier to separate yourself
from reality rather than facing it I the
bars out everything you've remembered is
a version of what has hasn't a semblance
of the past and I did have a job there
are other perspectives and there is the
truth
should you ever wished for Susan's okay
i am the son
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] continue
okay what's memory has been combed is no
longer accessible I need another trap
match let's get back to the job at hand
oh oh jennifer i always wanted to be
right was it worth it yes I'd have to
say it was worth it I'm Theresa
[ __ ] is going on here
my vision all [ __ ] up
now what the [ __ ] is happening what the
[ __ ] is happening
that match
that [ __ ] house was [ __ ] locked and
I've got to be getting me
still [ __ ] up what is this thing
[ __ ] is flickering all over the [ __ ]
place
come on Beth change
the wonderful wait what if I wasn't
there so where should we begin what do
you remember that don't be honest I'm a
little concerned about your current
mental state
vodka office there are certain things I
can help you with let your thoughts and
memories are your home
okay this is a little different in here
right does this change now
gonna lat yeah I'll hat tourney second
guess
we can I use a [ __ ] computer thing
huh the hippocampus is crimine any
change in here now
huh
there must be possible we can force
ourselves to deliberately forget through
EEG measurements we should be able to
capture the exact moment when I even
have been better you can change it in
here
there's [ __ ] going on in here
I respond your actions but your own race
will drive behavior John kinds of let's
say for example
here
okay later sometimes I get concerned
false memories
okay I'll be in the back office yeah I
gotta figure out of business from dragon
it's the back office [ __ ] am I looking
at and turn on the [ __ ] off again
I am NOT indicating the proper
credentials for you to be back here
please get out please be careful nobody
knows exactly what that control panel
does I think it's mislabeled yep it's
definitely mislabeled what did you think
was going to happen yeah that should be
more careful imagine what would happen
if I wasn't here to guide you oh yeah
when he [ __ ] disabled at [ __ ] patch
ok man I go back to the woodlands
anything
don't got match taco I've been waiting
for you this is the end again you've
chosen for yourself that good good good
it might have been different had you
taken another path but here you are how
does it feel isn't this what you've
always wanted yes it's okay you'll get
another chance depending on what you
believe
huh all right well I'm gonna say guys
that was so sound lad so thanks for
watching thanks for watching thank you